it's easy to get lost in Murphy Canada's
surreal installations but dig a little
deeper and you realize his work is made
up of millions of tiny pieces and that
every single little point represents a
piece of data that he's fed through a
neural network to show us his vision of
our future I was always like trying to
like speculate this idea of can data
become a pigment at the end the data is
a truly numbers that has no kind of in a
skin or skeleton but what I'm frankly as
an artist is find an algorithm that can
narrate the moment of data kind of like
make that invisible moment visible
enormous datasets inspire most of a
Nadal's art and he uses machine
intelligence and algorithms to create
visualizations what he calls data
sculptures like this piece called
machine hallucinations
he started by finding a hundred and
thirteen million images of New York
online and let the Machine learn from
the entire corpus of data and then we
also find a way to erase the humans from
this data and only focus on the
building's nature and environments that
is a collective memory of New York once
all of the images of people were removed
Anna Dahl was left with ten million
pictures of New York he fed them through
a machine learning algorithm that
generates visual associations as it
learns for example when it sees multiple
photos of the Statue of Liberty taken
from slightly different angles the
algorithm interpolates information to
help it create a moving shifting image
that represents the entire lifecycle of
the structure mission looks at this
information like a human being but it's
kind of more like a collective memories
than a personal memories because a
building in New York can be explored by
thousands of perspectives from multiple
angles from a different time of the year
it's more like an honest memory for a
machine because it feels more
totalitarian and like it feels
everything and everyone than just one
person and it all covered the walls in
the floor of a boiler room in a building
in lower Manhattan with this machine
interpreted dynamic landscape if you ask
him he'll tell you that the machine is
dreaming when a machine learns from
outputs and memories like this it can
create an alternative reality it look at
the patterns of the trees the buildings
and
nature the people every single thing
hidden inside this image corpus seeing a
machine giving a context of data and
creating and hallucinating outputs or
something like really inspiring in it
all created this piece to celebrate the
centennial of the LA Philharmonic using
half a million images thousands of audio
recordings and hundreds of videos from
the orchestra's archives he fed all that
into a series of algorithms that turned
it into these extraordinary projected
images by using measuring algorithms the
entire archive of LA Philharmonic
becomes a shape of three-dimensional
outputs we were able to see all these
data points be coming together or
disappearing and making kind of a new
sculptures and the building itself Frank
Gehry's Walt Disney Concert Hall became
part of the sculpture too I was always
like looking for inspiring buildings and
Frank Gehry became my hero and I rent a
car went to downtown it was 2:00 a.m.
the buildings light was off like there
was nothing around him and that night I
was really struck by an idea like what
will happen if this building can
remember like in a dream so he projected
the machine interpreted archives onto a
smaller model of the Walt Disney Concert
Hall once he settled on something he
liked he projected it onto the bigger
real-life building what we are doing is
another typical painting and a typical
sculpture but more like an experience
from a near future and when they come
together with sound data machine
intelligence and light and architecture
they have a new meaning and in kind of
symbiotic content connections I think I
was really hooked up by the idea of a
building can become an interface it can
be a boring advertising but it can be a
beautiful interface the ideation of a
human instinct become a part of a
machine
is really striking me like emotionally
Anna dhaan his team used 42 large scale
projectors with an astonishing 50k video
resolution to create a dramatic display
in downtown LA every night for 10 days
and not one of his favorite movies I was
8 years old when I watched the movie
Blade Runner
I was extremely inspired by the movie in
downtown Los Angeles a building suddenly
becomes alive and it has this cognitive
capacity of remembering and it has a
capacity of dreaming so this was all
like very high level science fiction
narratives and the futuristic dystopian
films exploration of more complex themes
echo a Nadal's interest in the
relationship between humans and
technology Ron Deckard and Rachael like
contemplates each other and has a
dialogue where Deckard defines Rachael
as a replicant it was a very interesting
moment or a human defines another
machine that is kind of this defining
what is real or what is not that that
kind of human consciousness and machine
consciousness were having its dialog
moment that was truly inspiring you
remember the spider that lived in a bush
outside your window the egg hatched
those aren't your memories there's
somebody else's I think in humanity we
have very certain findings that
transform who we are when we found the
fire we cook with it we create
communities with the same technology we
kill each other and destroy and clearly
AI is one of the discovery in humanity
that has a potential to make communities
or destroy each other
Anna defines data for his machine
intelligence collaborations everywhere
and when he learned that when data is
continuously being collected at the
Boston Airport he knew he'd found a gold
mine he turned it all into this project
called winds of Boston
I was always inspired by nature as an
inspiration from the like the wind
itself the water do the nature like a
core nature like aspect of motion theory
in life in general and I know this can
be an incredible opportunity like use
wind as it like a data and as a pigment
so we first located our data source from
the airport Logan Airport
the wind is extremely important for the
flight networks so we took a one-year
long wind data of Boston and this data
consists of the gust of speed and
direction and the temperature of the
weather and it all fed all this wind
data into a series of algorithms then he
built custom 13 foot tall LED screens to
display the visualized data and I
thought that algorithms can be an
incredible way of visualizing this
invisible pattern of wind and transform
them into a poetic like motion because
it's very inspiring that the machine can
find something interesting that I didn't
even think about it and and I found that
the true collaboration starts happen
there and sometimes machine gives
opportunities that I didn't think about
it and I do believe that is really
something that is inspiring for Humanity
that will most likely bring some new
kind of imagination methods that is not
discovered yet the inspiration for this
project called melting memories came
from a personal place I went to Istanbul
my hometown and my uncle just couldn't
remember where I am coming from and
apparently it was his first stage of
Alzheimer when this disease happens we
literally melt our memories our brain
tissue disappears but I also like was
very curious about scientifically
honestly what memory means like where
they come from what is the cognitive
like representation of a memory and the
images on these 20-foot tall LED screens
represent the real data behind that
process and these moments are really
trying to give a sense of a tangible
feeling of a memory I know that we are
not there
as technology that truly transcripts in
memory but it at least gives a glimpse
of an abstract language of a memory
that's one of those feelings that is
hidden in those algorithmic exploration
of data ended up partnered with
scientist at a neuroscience lab they
asked subjects to concentrate on
childhood memories and recorded all
their brain pulses using an EEG the data
itself is literally pulsing in a 4
milliseconds of a human brain activity
in the - location of brain from
hippocampus the frontal left lobe and
the algorithm symbolizes the moment of
remembering and it is how poetic moment
of this firing location into location of
the brain in a doll and his team created
custom software that transformed all of
that brain data into an artistic
interpretation of the neurons firing
another example of how we use this
technology to describe life I never
stopped thinking about data as a as a as
a mean of like material sometimes it can
be a wind data it can be a Wi-Fi
Bluetooth signal it can be a mission
intelligent decisions it can be a CPU
data GPU data it's honestly anything
that machine needs to understand life
can become a material for this
imagination one problem we had to solve
today is a visual discontinuity problem
ennahdha has built a team with expertise
in different fields to help him fulfill
his vision AI experts computer scientist
architects and designers and they're
working out a new workflow for a
data-driven public art project set for
Portland for this one a Nadal's letting
hundreds of thousands of images of
Portland and form both the projections
and the structure they'll be projected
on the team is using a 3d printer to
build a structure one panel at a time it
will ultimately be a 21 foot tall
sculpture I found that we were stuck in
this just virtual world I found that we
are in the screens to the flat world of
like imagination I was really looking
forward how we can take this mission
consciousness out of the screen and
bring it in 3d 3d world whatever is in
store for the future of an adult's work
machine learning will be the foundation
it's very clear that machines can really
capture our data machines can capture
our decisions our memories but it's not
clear what will happen to them and I
think also clearly the data we leave
behind is the memories of humanity my
obsession with this relationship is what
else we can do with that
[Music]